oh my god  so very nice you ready for what I need  the one more call this okay good talk  yeah guitar I love I want to be okay  okay it's so fun being the most hated  person at a wedding  these are not going away we thought it  would Misha for us in a room a cloud of  marijuana spec closes and how annoying  is Carrie mom why aren't you ready yet  [Music]  okay totally fine why don't we just have  a drink  and they can sort of game plan for what  might possibly be a stressful you guys  are so obsessed with yourselves and  something it's really not that  interesting what are you writing I'm  just making a note of what not to do at  our wedding  [Music]  very nice Oh give me another Bloody Mary  he's at emergency  you